let's talk about lebanon
you might have heard that things are bad
but you probably don't realize how bad
four out of five people are living in
poverty there are shortages of pretty
much everything people are fighting over
fuel and anyone who can leave
lebanon basically is a plane that's
crashing but hasn't crashed yet there's
finally a new government after more than
a year but the thing is in lebanon the
government is often part of the problem
it's the same political parties blamed
for years of corruption and
mismanagement at the end of the day it's
not really about the government
formation is that it is really about
what is this government going to do
lebanon is unraveling on so many fronts
and all the different crises are
compounding each other so what's
happening and why is it so hard to fix
things
to give you an idea of just how quickly
lebanon is collapsing you have to
realize that it's even worse than
venezuela a poster child of devastated
economies it took lebanon less than two
years to get to where venezuela
was over a six-year period after years
of corruption mismanagement and
dysfunctional politics lebanon's dealing
with a huge currency crisis
and that's at the root of so many other
problems right now
everything is much more expensive
inflation is very high
the currency has completely imploded so
here's what's going on in the late 1990s
the lebanese pound was pegged to the u.s
dollar the exchange rate was fixed at
1500 pounds for one dollar now the
problem with that is lebanon's economy
wasn't strong enough to really justify
that value it was sort of artificial for
a long time the government and banks
managed to prop up the currency to
maintain that peg but now they're at a
point where they just can't do that
anymore and so the currency has crashed
losing up to 90 percent of its value in
the last two years and that means
people's savings and salaries have
tanked
whatever you make you you make about
just 90 percent
less of what you made before
unfortunately yeah everything revolves
around this uh
currency your currency is worth less it
makes importing things much more
expensive for lebanon that's a massive
deal because it imports nearly
everything including all its fuel so now
on top of the currency crisis there's a
fuel crisis
the government simply can't afford to
buy enough and it's abandoned some of
the fuel subsidies that helped make fuel
affordable for ordinary people so now
you've got both shortages and super high
prices
so the fuel crisis is creating a domino
effect drinking water now costs four
times what it used to and the lights are
literally going out because there's no
fuel for generators constant
obstructions from
this is an example of electricity going
off you're talking about some places not
getting more than a couple of hours of
electricity a day this summer and when
it comes to hospitals when it comes to
people where you have young children or
elderly this is this is a health risk so
it only gets worse because now you've
got a health crisis too hospitals are
struggling the un has got involved even
supplying fuel to help keep generators
running and like other imports medicine
has become too expensive or hard to find
even ordinary drugs like paracetamol let
alone life-saving ones for diabetics or
cancer patients
so people like marina are stepping in
she set up a charity to coordinate
donations of medicine from abroad we
cross the red lines and
we're really facing a hard and harsh
times at the end this is not our job
this is the job of the state but since
we don't have a state we are doing this
job
that idea that the state is missing in
action well that's why things have
become so desperate lebanon is
definitely a rare case of a country with
virtually no viable state services
uh or social services or social
institutions the government has
completely imploded as an institution
delivery of basic services have
completely stopped and this isn't
exactly new it's almost as if lebanon is
in a permanent state of political crisis
and critics say part of the problem is
the system itself
now the way it works is that the three
biggest sects are guaranteed
representation that was the deal to keep
the peace after the civil war so for
example the president is always a
maronite christian the prime minister is
always sunni and the speaker of
parliament is shia but in reality it's
led to political gridlock infighting and
nothing really gets done it's really
about
you know
who gets which government sponsored
contracts what kind of company
affiliated with who um when you're
forming a government for example you
know it's not just about
who is the best person to handle the
ministry of economy it's whether the
president who is a marine christian
should pick that minister whether it's
the prime minister or somebody will pick
it
and it becomes a horse trading
situation you end up with a lot of
corruption and accusations that
politicians are only serving their own
interests not working for the good of
the country
a couple of years ago hundreds of
thousands of people protested to say as
much
[Music]
and after the horrific explosion in
beirut last year there was outrage
directed at politicians and so far no
one's been held to account
[ __ ]
what's happened recently is that the
political parties have finally agreed on
a new government after 13 months
lebanon's feuding politicians have now
agreed how to distribute power in a new
cabinets but most of the faces are
familiar like billionaire prime minister
najib makati who's had the job twice
already
he's trying to manage expectations but
they're already rock bottom i'm very
pessimistic about this government i
think this is this is just you know like
a morphine dose that was given to the
people in order to calm them down people
just feel that because this is a
returning prime minister this is his
third time as prime minister they say
well you know what doesn't matter if
they're calling the shots then we can't
expect the people that put us in this
crisis to get us out of it and there's a
lot that needs doing priority number one
is to get cash into the country and the
government's best bet is to secure a
bailout from the imf it's now planning
to reopen talks with them after the last
one stalled in 2020 but if the
government wants money it will also need
to present a recovery plan that includes
a bunch of reforms we need to
get dollars from the rest of the world
desperately in order to pump badly need
oxygen for the population but that only
stops the collapse this country has been
very badly managed for a very long time
we need a political transformation
if there's any chance of that happening
it could start with parliamentary
elections coming up in may but that's a
big if
just like fuel and medicine
hope that politicians will actually
change things is in seriously short
supply
if you found that useful check out our
recent explainer on al qaeda and click
that subscribe button so you don't miss
our next episode
[Music]